and the starting pitcher for the giants
is none other than the right-hander
johnny cueto cueto
coming off a brilliant start hey eugenio
suarez stands in we'll see what his
approach is here
two and two here's the pitch that one is
hit
to left field again not that deep
dickerson angling to his right and in
alex dickerson there to make the catch
and johnny cueto
with a real strong beginning even with
the first pitch
single off the bat of winker he throws
just eight pitches
in a scoreless first so the reds
scoreless malley to the mound and the
giants coming up
and tyler mally is the pitcher for
cincinnati
1-0 a 2.00 earned run average
here's alex dickerson dickerson's
hitting just 160.
a couple of home runs though four driven
in
ali gets the sign here's the
right-handers 0-2
fastball strike three called that's one
that started a ball
came back to the inside corner i think
that would go down as a quality pitch
it's strike three to get dickerson
looking
and the giants are down in order against
tyler malley in the first one of the
books
and nicosianos castillanos
also very aggressive in the first inning
he jumped on the first pitch he saw from
johnny cueto
fastball a little lazy fly ball to
center field
here it's nothing nothing but a really
good hitter at the plate with a chance
to put the reds ahead castellano stevens
in its second two down 1-1 pitch
he swings and it's a roller right back
to the mound got totally jammed cueto
backhands it
and flips it a hierarchy throw over to
first
for out number three good pitching there
from cueto to get through castellano
slater casalli and then johnny cueto
himself
coming up in the bottom of the third
nothing nothing giants in the reds
tyler naquin the batter he's got five
home runs
nick quinn also has 14 rbis
the 2-2 i'm gonna miss he struck him out
with a high fastball and that'll end the
inning
the reds strand mustache at second
for the giants it's the top of the order
coming up here in san francisco it's
nothing nothing
and tommy la stella stands in
foul tip caught five strikeouts for
tyler malley he is
dealing dickerson struck out looking in
the first
he's trying to get it going he's sitting
at 154 does not have a hit in the series
strike three on the corner dickerson
could not pull the trigger here
goes down looking belt came into his at
bat
in the second inning two for two
lifetime against smelly
and both hits were home runs swung at
the first pitch and hit a fly ball to
the left
in the second so 3-2 runner will be
going he is
and swinging and a miss by brandon bell
blew him away with a high fastball
seven punchouts through the first four
for tyler malley a scoreless ball game
donovan solano flew out to the right
fielder his first time up
so three and two will do it again
here's mally as he rocks back and now
throws and solano hits a little pop-up
shallow right field india going out it's
gonna fall
it falls in front of castiano and
there's the first hit for the giants
runner at first base with one out and
the batter is austin slater
struck out looking in the third here's
the o2
slater lines one right center field he's
done it again it's going to split
everybody
on the move is crawford picking it up as
nayquin
he's only playable to get it back into
the infield
crawford scores and the giants lead one
nothing
when i say he's done it again it's
exactly the same spot
that he hit the ball last night when he
knocked in buster posey
[Applause]
and that'll bring up casalli the sally
bounced out to third in the third
now the infield in and the 2-0 and a
ground ball into the hole backhanded at
short to throw home
not in time the slater slides away from
the tag
and it's two nothing and the batter is
tommy listella stella grounded to the
second baseman in the first he struck
out in the fourth
two two stella lines it into right
center field
castellanos with that arm here comes
cassalli to throw the slide
and the giants pick up another run it's
three nothing
the reds may want to review this
and in fact they are going to get a
review so the reds will have the umpires
take a look
if you look at casali's lead foot
did it actually come down on the plate
or was it hanging
over the plate when the tag was made and
they're going to call him out
so the call is overturned the reds get
the out at home
and the inning is over the giants get
two
in the fifth and we go to the
sixth inning and that'll bring up
gastianas castianus is
flied out to center and then he got
jammed and rolled one back to cueto
and the payoff here it is swing gonna
miss he got him with 93
is castianos is down swinging
for the first time strikeout number four
he went right at him and that pitch was
right down the middle of the plate
and uh dave gretchen is coming out cueto
seems to
have done something on that last pitch
he's not happy
i mean that was a max effort on that
last pitch
and he's going to depart
you can hear a groan from uh the people
here
that have come to enjoy watching plato
throw
so he did grimace after he threw it so
we're gonna have to find out as to
what's going on
with johnny cueto is he now heads into
the dugout as he takes the ball and he
kind of throws it on the floor of the
dugout
two on two out mauricio dubon is the
hitter this was dickerson's spot
dubon struck out in a pinch hit at bad
and then went in to play defense giants
lead two-nothing
little pop-up tough play for somebody
drop longoria scores
it's three nothing brandon belt one for
three with a bunt single today
now you stremski 90 feet away and that
one hard on the ground
india on the and that's the ending
so here is a eugenio suarez he is 0 for
3 in this game
the 02 pitch fastball struck him out
swinging 96 miles an hour
the game is over the series is over the
home stand is over and for the giants it
was a
very satisfying week here at oracle park